hi everyone it's Evan Carmichael I
wanted to make a quick video today to
answer a question from one of my readers
David about a service I used called PR
leads peer leaders a media service
that's gotten me into the New York Times
and Forbes magazine a whole bunch of
other media outlets and I wanted to make
this quick video today to talk about how
I use it how you can use it too so first
to David's question he wrote on one of
my blog posts the peer elite service
looks interesting so helps you can make
a video using your own experience of the
service to show us how it works or how
we can use best wishes did there is a
low reader and also active member in our
forum so I wanted this to the question
warm what do you sing about is on a
favorite will second these airs of all
those that I used to grow sness their
you groom your bisection I could let you
hear it
and it's a service again that I use and
how it works if you click on that link
basically what's gonna happen is
reporters sign up for this service and
they're looking for experts to talk
about the different stories that they're
working on
so reporters will post all the different
stories they're working on and say we
need an expert who can talk about XYZ
and as entrepreneurs we should be
experts on our different subject matters
so you want to be able to open yourself
up as the expert to talk about you know
and help them with whatever story
they're working on so it's a service its
$99 a month here and what's gonna happen
is you'll get emails every day from
reporters who are looking to potentially
talk to you so what it looks like if I
load up my email program you'll get
emails from a service called prof net
and that's PR leads and you can see
it'll come a couple times a day so you
know if you look three from June 7th as
an example and you can sign up for
different categories for me I signed up
for the business category because that's
most related to what I talked about and
if you click on the email what it will
show you is all the different stories
that reporters are working on and
they're looking for experts there's
different categories so in this one it's
Business Human Resources public
relations and it's all still related to
entrepreneurship and business which is
what I'm interested in and some of them
will be from niche magazines so this one
here is is human resources culturally
fit employees the magazine's benefits
selling so if I was
an HR consultant and I worked about you
know getting the culture fit right at
companies this could be a really cool
article for me to sign up for and talk
to the reporter the next one here is
public relations
how do preaches rebound after public
scandals that's from cnn.com
so if I was in a PR business this is a
great opportunity to be able to get into
CNN so you want to take a look at those
different opportunities if you scroll
down on that email what you'll see is
more details about every story that is
currently available so the benefits
selling one here's a little bit more
information it tells you who the
reporter is the magazine when their due
date is you want to pay attention to
that and make sure you get it in on time
and how to contact them the email
address same thing for the next one for
cnn.com it's by John Blake from CNN he
has a due date and here's his email
address to get in touch with him
so one of the things that I found to be
really effective is you want to make
sure you're pitching them not just how
great you are you don't want to write to
John and say hey John I'm a PR
consultant and I can help you you want
to be able to pitch in the story so I've
had pretty good success with PR leads
and there are other experts too that
you're going up against cuz you won't be
the only one on this service but what I
found being really useful is you want to
provide them as much of a story as you
can so a good example when Forbes posted
on PR leads there was about outsourcing
and I've done a lot of outsourcing with
my business and I didn't post and say
hey you know I've done a lot of
outsourcing please email me I told him
about exactly what I've done I've oh I
have work it for me I told him how I
found them what type of roles they had
where they're living currently and how I
run my business with all these
outsourced people and that turned out to
be an interesting story for him and he
had a few follow-up questions and he
posted it on Forbes magazine which is
great you know I could say I've been in
Forbes now you don't have to necessarily
always go for the top you can pick niche
ones that are really targeted towards
your industry but you want to try to
provide as much detail and give them a
story that they can use as much as
possible so that's one example of an
email that came through we can go back
again
you can just quickly browse through each
one that's what I'll do every morning is
look at each one and see is it
interesting to me or not again you'll
see them all over the map in terms of
different business backgrounds so HR
magazine here Albany Times Union AOL
small business and you can get into all
sorts of different media again depending
on the story that people are looking for
the other thing I found really useful is
you want to create a media page to talk
about all the experience that you've had
so what I've done if you go to any page
on my site you'll notice that the first
page in the navigation is about so if
you click on that it'll lead you to my
about page and on here the first thing I
show is all the different media that
I've been involved in or at least the
bigger ones the more recognizable names
so I've been in The New York Times in
Wall Street Journal and Forbes magazine
and it goes on and some of the more
respected and well-known brands I've
also included some of the TV stuff that
I've done and just taken screenshots to
show that I've been on TV and been
interviewed and then I put below to
arrange interview time you know please
contact me here's my email address so on
top of having a good story what the
report is looking for is that you really
are an expert so you want to have a page
you can send them to to say hey you know
I really know what I'm talking about and
I've been featured before nobody wants
to be the first one to feature you so
it's great if you've been featured
already if you haven't been featured yet
by anybody then start with the smaller
publications and use those as stepping
stones to get to the bigger ones so if
I'm trying to go after story what I'll
do is obviously give them all the
information I have and then I'll also
include this link and say you can also
check out some of the work that I've
done I've been featured in all these
different publications and on TV and
that helps provide them a little bit of
a safety net to show that hey you know
this guy really knows what he's talking
about and he is a establish expert so as
entrepreneurs again we should all be
experts in our industry and we should
know what we're talking about and media
coverage is great it's it's almost free
in this case you know it's 99 bucks a
month it's a lot cheaper than hiring a
media consultant to help you and it can
get you a lot of a business a lot of
recognition a lot more than advertising
can and again it's all off of here
pyaare leads just click learn more and
you can hopefully go on if you have any
success with it let me know so David I
hope that answered your question I hope
that helps if anybody else has a
question who wants to see another video
from one of my other tools let me know
if you enjoyed the video please give it
a thumbs up below and leave a comment
and I'd love to hear from you and stay
tuned for the next video
Cheers
you